d'ailleurs monsieur jean luc reitzer
bien monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
car elle porte aussi sur la cohérence de
certaines déclarations ministérielles
en effet alors que le paquet de
cigarettes neutre doit entrer en vigueur
le 20 mai prochain
la ministre de la santé a déclaré il y à
peu et je cite vouloir une augmentation
forte et significative du prix du tabac
le plus vite possible avant la fin du
quinquennat
se disant même favorable à un paquet de
cigarettes à 10 euros non seulement ces
propos ne respecte pas les engagements
du président de la république vis-à-vis
de la profession mais ils sont en plus
en contradiction avec les affirmations
de monsieur sapin ministre des finances
qui affirmait qu'il n'y aurait pas la
même année et le paquet neutre est
l'augmentation du prix du tabac alors
ses déclarations contradictoires au sein
du gouvernement ne peuvent naturellement
qu'inquiéter les buralistes
quant aux français nous savons tous ils
sont très sceptiques quant à
l'efficacité de ce paquet neutre comme
le montre d'ailleurs un récent sondage
madame touraine pousse dès maintenant à
une très forte augmentation du prix du
tabac alors que tout montre qu'une
hausse brutale a pour effet principal de
stimuler les achats sur le marché
parallèle
hors de tout contrôle et tous les
parlementaires frontaliers ici présents
pourront vous le confirmer il en va
d'ailleurs de même en australie qui a
adopté le paquet neutre alors pouvez
vous je ne sais pas qui me répondra mais
pouvez-vous réaffirmé que les
engagements pris par le président de la
république seront pour une fois tenu et
que je l'espère également nos buralistes
ne seront pas une nouvelle fois
malmenées voir condamner par votre
gouvernement
merci madame ségolène neuville va vous
répondre secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je veux d'abord
excusé l'absence de la ministre de la
santé marisol touraine qui est avec le
président de la république à lyon pour
une conférence internationale sur la
sécurité sanitaire
je veux vous répondre très clairement
sur la question que vous avez posé face
au fléau du tabagisme et en particulier
chez les jeunes ce fléau qui entraînent
près de 80 mille décès en france chaque
année
c'est à dire beaucoup plus que les
accidents de la route il y a finalement
deux camps il ya le camp de la
résignation et vie il y a le camp de
ceux qui veulent faire prioriser la
santé publique et c'est ce camp là que
le gouvernement a choisi et finalement
il n'y a pas une mesure miracle qui
pourra résoudre ce fléau du tabagisme en
france et en particulier chez les jeunes
c'est un ensemble de mesures qui font
que la consommation de tabac peut
diminuer le paquet neutre a déjà
largement montré son efficacité pourquoi
parce que le l'emballage tel qu'il est
le packaging comme on dit le l'emballage
avec des couleurs attrayantes avec des
formes attrayante avec des logos
attrayant à la mode
eh bien ça fait que les jeunes achètent
plus de paquets de tabac quand les
paquets sont à la mode et on sait bien
que le fait de passer au paquet neutre
est donc les textes sont sortis hier lé
décret y afférent avec eux donc
l'interdiction de produire des paquets
autre que neutre à partir du 20 mai et
la distribution qui pourra continuer
jusqu'au 20 novembre pour les
distributeurs et les buralistes auront
quelques semaines de plus pour écouler
leurs paquets
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
ministre a annoncé hier que il pourrait
épauler leurs paquets jusqu'au 1er
janvier 2017
c'est avec des mesures comme ça et
également avec l'augmentation du prix du
tabac que nous viendrons à bout de ce
fléau
merci madame la parole est à monsieur
nicolas bailly